intervention musclée de la brigade
anticriminalité il s'agit en fait une
démonstration d'interpellation de la bac
avec en prime une réelle utilisation du
tazer sous les applaudissements du
public
dommage qu'on n'ait pas ce qu'il y ait
un prêt déclenchement du taser donc une
belle interprétation j'ai trouvé
vraiment très bien avec ça reflétait en
tout cas ce qu'ils font j'ai
l'impression que c'était ceux qui le
doit vivre au quotidien
autre démonstration qui a attiré
l'attention celle du maître chien le
gendarme loïc balta et son fidèle
compagnon
ice-t forme un duo inséparable depuis
trois ans un maître de chien à un seul
chien qui travaillait avec lui on a des
suppléments pour s'occuper des soins
quand on ne peut pas s'occuper de lui
mais il ne pourra jamais travailler que
avec le maître de chaque qui a titré lui
il a été formé en pistage défense il a
surtout un rôle de pistage de recherche
des personnes puisque au niveau de l'île
on a un besoin de recherche des
personnes disparues
ces rencontres de la sécurité permettent
donc aux forces de l'ordre d'expliquer
leur mission est de répondre à toutes
sortes de questions j'ai demandé quels
types d'interventions il y avait sur
l'île
j'ai demandé également au niveau des
statistiques parmi toutes les
interventions lesquelles représentaient
ont représenté des menaces réelles ou la
population qu'on voit beaucoup ce qui se
passe dans les films et on se demande si
c'est vraiment proche de la réalité ou
pas en fait
d'autres s'intéressent à leur quotidien
le fonctionnement des radars mobiles et
veulent savoir comment sont effectués
les contrôles de vitesse j'ai essayé de
me renseigner sur commence à flasher
commence au fait c'est bon c'est
toujours bon à savoir
et puis non mais c'est intéressant
d'échanger avec les forces de londres
dans d'autres conditions que au bord de
la route quand on se fait arrêter ce
type de manifestation a pour but de
permettre à certains de trouver leur
voie de susciter des vocations à
l'instinct de ces jeunes
sapeurs-pompiers âgés de 13 à 17 ans ils
sont une trentaine informations augmente
et à rivière salée
ça apporte de la connaissance de la
rigueur et du sérieux donc qu'est-ce que
je fais même qu'en dehors du
sapeur-pompier
pourquoi être jsp
tout d'abord pour devenir conflit à la
suite de la population et puis à prouver
mon rêve
tous rêvent de devenir pompier puis
devenu pompier par la suite j'aimerais
bien monter à la bspp la baguette de
paris une opération de communication
pour rassurer la population la mettre en
confiance et montrer qu'au delà de la
fonction que derrière les uniformes
il y a aussi des femmes et des hommes